Justine - Hey guys it's Justine and
today we're checking out
these brand new headphones by Dolby.
These are the Dolby Dimension headphones.
These feature a few new things
that I'm really excited to test out,
most of which, there's
this thing called LifeMix.
You can put the headphones
on and you can decide
how much of the outside
noise you wanna hear
and how much of your
content you wanna hear.
That's gonna be really fun,
because my sister and I
do edit a lot side by side.
She'll be editing a video,
I don't wanna actually hear her video,
but she wants to be able
to hear me talking to her
and vice versa.
I'm also excited about the Cinematic Sound
when you move your head,
you'll be able to hear
the change in whatever it
is that you're watching
so it's really like you are so immersed
that you're actually there.
A huge thank you to Dolby
for partnering with me on this video.
When they reached out
about these headphones
I was so excited, because
I'm such a huge fan of Dolby.
When you hear the name
Dolby, you automatically know
that it's going to be
something that is incredible
because they've been around for so long
and it's one of those
names that you just trust.
So I just knew that this is
something that I had to try out.
(light electronic music)
Look at these.
They're on like a little pillow.
These headphones look so comfortable,
makes me wanna take a nap.
So, nice weight,
a really,
really nice feel.
They fit me perfectly, I
didn't have to adjust anything.
Am I yelling? I might be yelling.
Anytime I put headphones on
I automatically start yelling
because I can't really hear myself.
It's got a little L
and the R inside there.
This is so comfortable,
it has like a nice padding up at the top
and this is like a perfect
fit over top of your ears.
Sometimes I feel like
these types of headphones
can be a little bit overpowering,
but they sit just perfectly,
they're extremely comfortable.
I wish that I could put
these on your little head.
Here, let's try them.
(electronic music)
Well how does that feel?
I wish that you could experience it.
It's the hardest part
when I'm making videos
it's how do I accurately
describe what I'm feeling,
and I try really hard.
I'm sometimes not good
ad describing my feelings
but I'm feeling pretty
excited about these.
Let's see what else is inside here.
I think that Dolby should also
consider making bed sheets
because this is something
that I would like to take a nap in.
You guys get in there.
Well that is so soft.
So what I think it's
really cool about these
is you can pair three
separate devices to it
at the same time, and you
can switch between them.
So a lot of times I'll be on my phone,
I'll be on my iMac and
I'll be on my laptop
especially when I'm traveling
I want to switch between
my music or my editing,
and really, it's just
great to be able to have
this one press of a
button to switch between
all of the things that are connected.
This also acts as touch
control, so if you tap twice,
you can toggle between LifeMix
and active noise cancellation
and there's an accompanying
app that goes with this
so you're able to control
just how that mix sounds.
And you can control your headphones.
So there's Virtualization
and Head Tracking.
This is where you can pair
each one of your devices,
that corresponds to each of the buttons
that you have on the headset,
so if I wanna connect my
phone, it's the first one
and when I connect my laptop and iMac,
those will be the next two.
So I guess now that I have this set up,
I need to play something.
Let's listen to the new
Imagine Dragons album.
(electronic music)
- I wish
so you could experience this.
Okay, I wanna check out the LifeMix.
So to do that I gotta tap twice to toggle.
(volume of music decreases)
Hello?
Oh my God! This is so weird.
What, is ha--
Woo!
Oh my God.
This is so silly.
I do tend to overreact a lot
but this is unlike anything that
I feel like I've really
experienced in headphones before.
So when I double tap,
right now
I can't hear myself even talking.
All I hear is the music.
I double tap, that activates the LifeMix,
so it's like microphones
are now picking up
what is around me.
Like, I can hear myself
inside of my head playing
while my music is playing.
That's the only way that I can explain it.
This is
so
wild.
So if you've ever had headphones on
while you're recording something
and the only way that I
can kind of explain it
is you put the headphones on
you can also monitor yourself talking
it's picking up my voice.
Oh my gosh I can't wait to try this.
I can't wait to get Jenna's reaction
she has no idea.
Like, I read about what this feature was.
This is not.
There's also a little charging dock.
So I'm gonna try and give you guys
an audio example of what I'm hearing.
Picture right now that you
have the headphones on.
And this is what it sounds like
if I was talking to you right now.
(volume of music increases)
So you can't really hear me,
it's muffled, it's, you know, like
Justine I can sort of hear you
but I'm listening to music
and I can't hear you.
Now when I turn these on
with that LifeMix
this is what it sounds like.
So it's kind of like,
everything is at a perfect mix
my voice is recorded into the song
so everything is just,
it's called LifeMix for a reason.
What?!
I need to go watch some content
I need to connect the rest of my devices
there's so many things
that I wanna do now.
I need a moment.
Jenna!
Dude, these are so freackin' cool.
You're gonna see, you're gonna see soon.
You're gonna see so, so soon.
Hi Matty!
I'm trying to film my video but
we've got our little doggy.
So you guys can see
there's three different
little sections right here.
Excuse me. (laughs)
I am so, so sorry.
Okay, so the three buttons
those correspond--
(laughs) whatever it is it's connected
so as you can see right
there the first one is lit up
and that is the iPhone.
So now I'm gonna connect
my MacBook if I'm allowed.
(whispers)
So now let's connect the MacBook.
(laughs) He's trying to
nudge my computer off.
Okay so Dolby Dimensions,
we're gonna connect.
There we go, the MacBook is now connected.
Now that the MacBook is connected
I have the Virtualization
and the Head Tracking on
so what this means is I'm going to be
so fully immersed in my film.
I've downloaded Ready Player One
so let's hit play.
No freaking way.
So when I tilt my head,
it's surrounding me.
Okay, now watch this.
- [Jenna] You're yelling.
- What did you say?
- (screams of excitement) Okay.
This has built-in microphones,
so it's picking up the sound around me
and completely mixing in what I--
Talk to me.
- [Jenna] What do you want for dinner?
- No way.
Oh.
I love dinner, okay wait.
So I can turn it down
with the touch controls,
I can turn it up.
So the cool thing about
that is when I'm doing this
it's turning down my
movie and I can still--
Say something.
- [Jenna] Dinner.
- I can hear you, you're saying dinner.
And when I double tap and turn it back up.
I'm back in my movie.
- [Jenna] No dinner.
- This is so cool!
You have to try this.
You have to. Like, I
can't even explain it.
Jen, you gotta try it.
Okay, you gotta get over here.
It's so hard to explain to
them what I'm experiencing
so I'm gonna try to
make you experience it.
- Okay
- So we're gonna put these on.
- I could do it.
- Oh.
- Put them on your ears.
- I know, like I just watched you do it.
- Okay, turn it up a little.
- Oh.
- Okay now double tap on it.
Hello?
Can you hear me? Can you hear me?
- It's like you're in my head.
- I know.
- But I'm on my own head.
- But now Imagine Dragons
is also in my head.
But it's like a perfect mix,
so you can still hear me.
Now turn down the music,
because when you turn the music down,
you still hear whatever is around you
in your head.
- So I turned the music down
so now you're just in my head.
- Yes.
- I'm like, not reacting
'cause I'm trying to
process what's happening.
- It's the craziest thing,
that's why I freaked out upstairs.
Now this is something
else I wanna show you.
- (sings) It's so weird!
- I know.
- 'cause I sound loud.
You-- You're-- Everyone is--
Wow.
- They're in your head.
- I like the volume control.
That's very, very convenient.
- I know.
- Can I help you?
- Are you enjoying them?
- Yeah, you're ruining my speakers.
(both laugh)
- These are so cool.
- Sounds really good to.
- I know.
- Ah, these are mine now.
- Bring back my phones!
(electronic music)
So these are definitely the
perfect headphones for me
for editing, and if you also are like me
and will binge watch an
entire season of a show
and don't even think twice about it,
these are also perfect for it
because you can still be
immersed into your show
but also now completely lose
track of the outside world.
Unless you want to, you just double tap.
This reminds me of
something from Black Mirror.
Like this is,
this is, I'm living in a Black
Mirror episode right now.
Like this is the future, this is--
Oh wow, I can hear everything.
Can't hear anything.
A huge thank you to Dolby,
you guys, this is incredible
and I'm so excited for people
to be able to experience this.
- [Jenna] I wish we would
have these before because
every time like you would watch a show
and I didn't watch it yet,
there would be like spoilers
so I can't hangout with you.
- I know.
- [Jenna] 'Cause I will hear the spoilers.
- Okay guys, if you want more information
about these headphones,
I will put a link in the description.
And be sure to subscribe to
our channel for more videos,
and be sure to like this
video if you enjoyed it.
And that's it.
I'll see you guys
in the next video.
(upbeat music)